what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are in the second part of our
discussion on Dark Knight's metal which
is kind of crazy but one of the things I
want to do here you know before we
really jump into this is I want to talk
about the endless for a second because
this was a debate that started in this
video or in the last video that we did
in part one spilled over into the green
lantern video and then as I imagine
holding me back in this one again I
watched a video that imaginary axis has
on the endless I don't know if you guys
have seen it I'll post a link down in
the description
I'll watch imaginary axis all the time
it's one of my favorite channels to
check out but the whole idea of the
endless is that people kind of look at
them in weird ways you know take for
example the concept of death of the
endless a lot of people look at death of
the endless and say that is the end-all
be-all definitive representation of
death more or less you know death of the
endless is death and a lot of people
usually cite the Sandman series as
worthy endless originated and so it
makes sense to say whatever the Sandman
series says is what's absolutely true
which is not an unreasonable stance to
take if you read Sandman issue number 48
for example you'll see the statement
that the endless are there embodiments
dream is the embodiment of dreaming
death is the embodiment of death and so
on and so forth but if you go when you
read Captain Atom number 42 they'll
basically say that's not necessarily
true that you have death of the endless
and then you have like black racer which
represents the death for speedsters and
then you have necron who represents
death for the Green Lanterns and they
all just are equal there's just
personifications of death different
people see at different ways as far as
I'm aware
DC's never come out and definitively
said note the way the Neil Gaiman
explains it is absolutely right that's
the way death works you have death of
the endless everybody else is just an
expression of the endless so you know is
just a personification of death as a
part of him or something along those
lines and that's it DC's never done that
before so it's really just kind of
whatever you want it to be when it comes
to the concept of dream of the endless I
do not believe there is another
counterpart to that version in DC comic
so that creates kind of a weird scenario
because it really isn't anybody out
there but it is somewhat of an
interesting scenario because it's just
one of these circumstances where you
have multiple entities representing the
same thing and then DC doesn't really
take any steps to consolidate it but the
fact remains in the last video we
basically left off with the idea that
there was this explanation of the dark
multiverse there is the main DC
multiverse and then on the backside
there's a dark multiverse but we don't
really know anything about it the only
thing we know is that there is a
substance
called in metal and this n that'll is
effectively a key that unlocks the door
and allows a person to enter the Dark
multiverse or if a person in possession
of in metal in the dark multiverse it
would allow them to enter the positive
multiverse basically the main DC
Multiverse and so the idea is that when
this whole explanation was happening
Batman did what Batman does and he stole
that little fragment of in metal and
took off now again this kind of makes
sense but keep in mind this whole story
is really in a lot of ways designed to
feed into the existing status quo of
Bruce wayne/batman usually keeps things
to himself he's one of those guys where
he basically comes along and says no one
is as smart as me I'm not cocky about it
I'm not arrogant about it it's just the
way things are and so with that being
the case I'm the person best suited to
pursue this goal and to figure out what
it is that's going on in truth it's a
lack of trust on Batman's behalf towards
the other members of the Justice League
and everybody who's involved but keep in
mind we also have things like government
agencies who were involved and Batman
knows really better than anybody else
that those government agencies can't be
trusted if in metal is this wildly
powerful material that can give people
powers and it fell into the hands of
like Amanda Waller of the Suicide Squad
that would be a terrible scenario for
almost anybody and so when Batman's mind
if all this stems back to the idea that
there's some sort of untold evil out
there that exists outside the multiverse
and in metal is the key to unlocking it
he's the best person to figure out how
it works and so in the aftermath of
Batman
stealing this a little shard of in
fettle the last shard in existence and
then racing off it's this massive
pursued by the various members of the
Justice League to track him down and
again this is really kind of interesting
here but it also shows the cunning
nature of the bat family in a sense that
you've got everybody hunting for Batman
you've got Superman
you've got Green Arrow you've got John
Constantine and Zatara you've got all
kinds of characters hunting for Batman
when it comes to the character of Bruce
Wayne he's seen and done at all this in
conjunction with how intelligent he is
means that there would be almost no way
to stop him if he decided he wanted to
disappear and so they're hunting in
every conceivable place that Batman
would go to not only that because of the
fact that this spills out into almost
every conceivable a conceivable facet of
the DC universe they effectively seem to
trace Batman down to the Amazon
rainforest and this is cool because you
basically
got Damian Wayne driving this vehicle
and just like talking trash to Wonder
Woman this is why I love Damian Wayne
you know it rent time I love Damian
Wayne I don't care people hate him I
don't you know Damian Wayne is that one
of the best characters in the DC
Universe and there's no arguing that
point that's just the way it is he's
like this little kid who is one of the
best assassins in the world and doesn't
take any lip off anybody and it's
amazing I absolutely love Damian Wayne
but the other half of this is that as
they go through and they start tracking
down Batman or at least believe they've
tracked down Batman you've got Aquaman
you've got all these characters popping
up out of the woodwork you've got the
flash chasing him down only for us to
begin finding out these versions of
Batman are not Bruce Wayne and that's
why it is that I love Scott Snyder's
writing is because when is basically
revealed that the version of Batman they
see is actually Nightwing it basically
goes all the way back to the very
opening story of the court of owls and
Scott Snyder's run this hologram
technology that Dick Grayson uses but
it's the exact same hologram technology
he uses when it came to the opening
story for court of owls when he looked
like the Joker and so with this
happening once they enter into a realm
where there's nothing but trees and all
these different bat men are captured
Dick Grayson pulls out a little piece
just this little bitty flower this
little bitty thing that basically has a
name that translates into the terrible
Green beatdown everybody panic everybody
freaks out Wonder Woman's first response
is oh my god where are we at in the NiO
cyborg responds Mike we gotta go and the
reason why is because of the fact that
they're in the Parliament of trees
they're in the realm of Swamp Thing now
remember Swamp Thing is one of the more
popular characters when it comes to DC
Comics even if in name only I mean
people know of the name Swamp Thing they
may not know the intricacies of his
character but they do know of the
concept but the largest reinvention of
sorts when it came to Swamp Thing
actually took place during the run of
Alan Moore he basically established this
idea that there had been a litany of
swamp things before you know the the
Alec Holland version they people were
reading at the time and there was this
concept called the Parliament of trees
now the very idea here is that there is
basically this giant hive mind
more-or-less of plant life across a
planet earth and the parliament of trees
selects a person every generation to
basically be its protector and that's
what Swamp Thing is Swamp Thing is a
protector of sorts when it comes to
the plant life that exists on earth the
fact remains here when it comes to Swamp
Thing he is almost this totally
indestructible force and largely
considered to be one of the most
powerful characters that exists out
there in the sense that if you were to
destroy the swamp things physical form
so long as plant life exists on the
planet he's on he can reconstitute
himself not only that his strength is
pretty extreme is pretty intense
he's extremely capable in terms of what
he's able to do and he actually
incapacitates the entirety of the
Justice League not only that we end up
finding out that was Superman kind of be
in The Last Man Standing that what ends
up taking place here is he deduces where
Batman is in the sense that with
everybody disguising themselves as
Batman the real Batman is actually in
the back of the truck being driven by uh
by Damian Wayne now this is one of the
coolest parts of the story because of
course Superman swoops in and basically
grabs Batman and whisks him off but we
get this really really cool explanation
in terms of what's going on and this is
why I say Scott Snyder's Batman is so
cohesive because it's his whole run at
the beginning of new 52 running all the
way up to endgame and then a few of the
stories afterwards and then it's
basically this tying all of that
together for those of you guys who saw
my new 52 run of the videos that we did
on Batman bear with me because there's
probably a lot of people who haven't and
if you haven't seen those I highly
suggest you go back and watch them
because this ties into everything what's
basically explained here is that there's
something that's going to going to take
place called on mantling or at least it
has been taking place and this all ties
back into Final Crisis during the Final
Crisis event when Batman was hit with
the Omega sanction of Darkseid and he
was sent all the way back to the early
days of humanity the character of
Barbados first saw him he first
witnessed Bruce Wayne what ended up
happening is that with Barbados
basically witnessing Bruce Wayne what he
did is set in motion a series of events
that would ultimately culminate in this
particular scenario and so it's
basically Barbados playing this game
that was designed to span thousands and
thousands and thousands of years
basically resulting in this particular
situation but a brunt of the scenarios
that took place didn't happen except
within the last few years the first part
was during the events of court of owls
during the events of court of owls when
Bruce Wayne was trying to figure out who
the court was and ultimately learned the
court had existed for eons and was
basically turning people who had died
into their own personal service their
own personal assassins Bruce Wayne was
captured by the court and subjected to
their labyrinths in
so he had consumed some of the water in
order to keep himself in going crazy
this water contains something called
electrum now we know from the court of
owls that electrum basically existed
alongside Dionysian Dionysian was a
substance that could basically give
people longevity it could allow them to
live for an extremely long amount of
time dionisije emits self was
established as a chemical that existed
on earth and in its most pure form was
first met by Vandal Savage basically an
immortal man who consumed dionisije
emply making himself immortal along the
way a Dionysian basically became impure
the Joker eventually encountered it and
so long as the Joker went back and
consumed Dionysian he would always live
and he would always recover from his
wounds during the events of Batman
in-game when Batman was believed to have
died at the hands of the Joker he had
basically consumed Dionysian to bring
himself back this ran into promethium
which allowed him to return is Batman
following the events of the Batman in
game's storyline and then that
ultimately ran into in metal when he
exposed himself to it in creating his a
vice that was basically used at the
start of the whole Dark Knights medal
and the casting and the forged but the
whole idea here is that over the course
of the last several years however many
years that maybe Batman has been
systematically exposed to these
different metals to four particular
metals to elect him to Dionysian to
promethium and then eventually to in
metal all these metals have existed in
DC Comics over the years it's DC
basically grabbing these materials
adding a couple new ones and then
consolidating them all together in
saying they're not just arbitrary metals
that exist out there they are important
and so Batman's biggest concern is that
there is a fifth metal and if he's
exposed to it he will become the doorway
he will become the means by which
Barbados and all of his forces will be
teleported to the positive multiverse
but Batman doesn't know how to stop it
the problem is that in the middle of
this whole thing Superman punches a hole
through Batman it's crazy he punches a
hole right through and what a woman
shows up and says he's basically just
stalling and that's when we find out
this is not Batman this is Clayface and
that's why I say this is so cool all
these little twists and turns it always
occurs they sort of come out of nowhere
right you just like oh my god Superman
killed Batman Batman said something to
piss him off as Superman just punched a
hole in his chest I mean that's that's
the initial that's the initial thought
here and then you find out that it's
just Clayface now the reason why is
because
man distracted in the moment believing
this is Batman basically just kind of
jumped on to it but remember Superman
memorized Batman's heartbeat as one of
the the kind of things the two of them
have in common in the sense that over
the course of DC's publication history
while Superman and Batman have fought
each other largely out really only after
the events of Dark Knight Returns they
had been friends for years and years and
years and while this version of Superman
and this version of Batman are basically
discovering each other for the first
time the fact remains that they are
forming a friendship and in order to
make sure that one of his closest
friends is always safe Superman always
knows the heartbeat of Batman he can
always hear it in the same way he can
always hear the heartbeat of Lois Lane
and his son Jonathan Kent and so in this
moment what is up happening is we
basically transition off to Batman once
he's actually in the tomb of Khufu in
the valley of Kings more or less of
course Khufu basically being caught
being Hawkman but the goal of Batman is
to grab the mace of Hawkman grab the
mace of harder harder haul owing to the
idea that Barbados had at some point
along the line walked the earth
presumably something happened and he was
cast into the dark multiverse we don't
know what that event was we just know
that it happened the rationale of Bruce
Wayne here is that if Barbados was
basically defeated by the mace of Carter
Hall which presumably is what sent
Barbados to the dark multiverse then the
idea of Batman is to travel all the way
back to the early days when he first
arrived in the past during the events of
Final Crisis fine Barbados use the mace
and kill him before all of this can
happen it's the only thing that man
knows to do this is irrational it's
unreasonable it's not normally something
Batman would do and what this is
designed to do is highlight the
desperation of Bruce Wayne the other
half of this is Batman intends to
basically jump back into the past using
the Omega sanction of Darkseid
now again what this is designed to do is
hit back to the events of Darkseid war
remember Darkseid war was basically the
last Justice League story and it dealt
with the idea of Darkseid going
head-to-head with the anti-monitor and
Darkseid himself dying and then being
reborn as a baby after which he was
taken by his daughter Grail
so what this is designed to say is DC
hasn't forgotten about that stuff all
that's still in continuity and we'll
probably see all that unfold somewhere
along the line the problem with this is
that in the middle of this massive set
of events we end up having this
revelation that the temple of Khufu had
long since been destroyed and they're
not actually there this is all just one
giant ruse
and the ruse has been set up by the
court of owls this all goes back to the
very beginning of scott Snyder's run
which is why I say you should definitely
check out all those videos when the
court of owls first popped up in DC
Comics when Scott Snyder first made them
it was basically just this clandestine
organization that was just bent on
dominating the world and ruling things
from behind the scenes always being in
control what we end up learning here is
that somewhere along a line there was
the Parliament of owls a group that
worship birds and then another group
broke off another aspect of the of the
Parliament of owls broke away and
started worshipping Barbados and so in
response to this because of the fact
that Barbados had set in motion the idea
that Bruce Wayne would eventually be the
gateway by which he could enter the main
DC Universe the court of owls that
warship Barbados began setting all these
things in motion they began carrying out
the grand plans of Barbados himself and
so they're the ones who have been
working behind the scenes what this
means is that everything that's happened
in a story that's been written about
Batman by Scott Snyder has all served
the purpose of the court of owls working
behind the scenes to make sure that
Batman would become the Gateway after
being exposed to these five metals to
allow Barbados to enter the positive
multiverse it's a huge revelation I mean
this is massive and scale and so
ultimately what we learned is this last
metal is called bat mania now this is
actually kind of cool and there's an
interesting name but the idea of it
being called that mania is not new this
goes all the way back to Batman number
45 with a new 52 and the way that I
understand it the idea was that there is
a woman called Jerry powers and she had
basically created this Collider and the
idea was that there was the periodic
table in the metals within it but the
goal of the collider was to basically
just start smashing atoms together for
the purpose of creating new elements and
where the court of Alice was aware of
what it was as she was doing they
basically let it happen and the reason
why was because inevitably she would
basically create that main IAM she would
create this last metal that would be
needed in order to basically bring
barbados into the positive multiverse
and so with batman basically being
exposed to batman IAM all five metals
have been exposed directly to him he is
now the gateway and as a result he's
basically teleported away to the dark
multiverse and in his place comes
barbados and all of his forces the whole
idea the whole question that people have
is who's barbados as a character what
going on with him what's he capable of
and why is he here the sheer power that
Barbados possesses is brought to bear
when he confronts Superman and Wonder
Woman what he does is touch them and
when he does that he begins draining the
life energy directly out of them this is
an insane level of power this is a level
power on par with gods if their power
can be drained away in that capacity
what does that say about the flash what
does it say about the Green Lantern what
does it say about all these other
superheroes out there do they stand a
chance and that's the question the story
is asking once we get to the end if this
guy can show up and take two of the most
powerful pieces off the chessboard what
hope does anybody else stand with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come this explain it make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the robb pork if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like man's
stories amazing and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]